in his first public comments since
announcing a plan to withdraw from
official duties
Prince Harry says he had no other option
but to cut most of his royal ties as you
might expect it is all over Britain's
front pages this morning Harry gave an
emotional speech last night after Queen
Elizabeth announced the highly
anticipated details of the new
arrangement for him and his wife Megan
it's an extraordinary break for a couple
who had hoped to introduce it seems a
more progressive era for Britain's
Royals Charlie daggers at buckin palace
with more on the story Charlie what are
they saying in the UK today Oh Gayle you
know they said they wanted out and
they're out they're out out but the
details of this Agreement outline a
significant split between the couple and
the rest of the royal family once Megan
were married we were excited for those
reasons it brings me great sadness that
it has come to this it has come to this
laid out by the Queen and a courteous
but clear divorce statement gone is the
use of the royal titles his in Her Royal
Highness Don is the public funding
they'll pay back the 3.1 million dollars
in taxpayer money spent renovating their
Frogmore cottage home near Windsor
Castle if the Queen was feeling the
strain she wasn't showing it as she
attended church yesterday in her
statement she said Harry Megan and
Archie will always be much-loved members
of my family but gone too are the
military titles and patronage is awarded
to Prince Harry after serving two terms
in Afghanistan he will no longer attend
events in uniform Harry said that one
hurt but at an event for his HIV charity
sent to Bali
he said the couple's work would continue
what I want to make clear is we're not
walking away and we certainly aren't
walking away from you our hope was to
continue serving the Queen the
Commonwealth and my military
associations but without public funding
unfortunately that was
what is now possible is the couple can
begin building their own brand and there
has been speculation they intend to
establish a foundation similar to the
Obamas it means that Megan in particular
will be able to support causes of
women's empowerment that people in the
palace here would think were too
political
Robert Lacey is a royal historian and
consultant for the Netflix series the
crown and now unburdened by the royal
family freedom is a big element in this
that's what you people have always been
about and that's what they sense in
North America and that's what they want
to enjoy and I hope they do and I'm sure
they will well for the time being anyway
it's business as usual we just got some
information this morning from the palace
saying that Harry attended an African
Investment Summit this morning the point
is he'll be doing these official duties
and engagements until the agreement
kicks in this spring Tony mr. Lacey's
right there we got people freedom thing
a lot a lot okay thank you very much
yeah it is very complicated one thing
that wasn't in the pieces that that
interesting phrase from Prince Harry the
decision I made for my wife and I yeah
but do you all know that they'd
certainly made that decision together I
think it was nice that he phrased it
that way because she's gotten she was
getting so blasted and hammered in the
bridge that's trying to take the burden
on himself that's how I took it I have
no inside information about that but
clearly they made that decision together
yeah